Season 1 of House of the Dragon is almost
as good and if not just as good as the first
four seasons of game of thrones.
That’s a very high commendation to pin onto
the show, but I think it’s more leaning
towards the almost as good since there were
a couple of aspects holding the season back
from perfection.
Firstly let’s go into the glaring positives
and talk about the plot of the season.
House of the Dragon is in a weird spot where
the meat of the story is later on and right
now they primarily have to do a tonne of set-up.
Most shows given the same task would be pretty
terrible since they’d be overly expository
driven and the plot wouldn’t be engaging
enough to enthrall the audience.
But here in House of the Dragon, they somehow
make the story riveting throughout every episode,
despite the limitations of the story not being
as grand or crazy as Game of Thrones.
They do this by having a consistent presence
of entertaining conflict that simultaneously
explores the intricacies of every character.
We don’t just sit here and have someone
tell us the histories of house Targaryen or
house Hightower, and instead, we witness the
rich characters work to overcome heaps of
obstacles that simultaneously builds them
into concrete characters with fully established
traits and personalities.
Even side characters like Rhaenys and Corlys
are incredibly detailed and scenes in which
we explore their complex motivations like
Corlys’ quest for power and Rhaenys’ love
for her family are entrancing.
This is essentially catalyzed by the debacle
of wanting to get entangled in royal politics,
so the conflict works for both interesting
story progression and character progression.
Each episode has a micro problem that needs
to be solved and that’s something a lot
of shows forget.
Normally most time and attention is spent
on the macro problems, but here, the emphasis
is put on small conflicts that develop characters.
For other shows, these minor obstacles generally
act as filler, however that isn’t the case
here.
Whether that’s Rhaenyra overcoming the responsibilities
of marriage, childbirth, loss, or love, the
writers essentially send every character down
an insane obstacle course of conflict that
sets them up for the oncoming war.
That on its own is pretty impressive from
a writing standpoint, but what makes this
even crazier to grasp, is having so many scenes
with an ensemble of main characters interacting
with one another.
This is something that David and Dan really
dropped the ball on for how underdeveloped
and awkward their group scenes were in the
later seasons, but the writers in this show
handle it very well.
Whether that’s the last supper, the funeral
of Laena, the wedding dinner, or any small
council scene.
The attention to detail and thought that’s
put into every microscopic character beat
floors me and the character gets to shine
brightly.
The coverage always accounts for small character
reactions that act as development for them
that doesn’t require dialogue.
Like the entire post-funeral scene where every
character is glaring at one another and just
from their expressions alone, you can easily
tell their views of one another.
The ensemble scenes are always a joy to watch
and it never feels like the writers are leaving
out any important interactions.
Like when you think about it in Game of Thrones
season 8, why did Arya never have a scene
with Daenerys given that she idolized the
independent and badass nature of her ancestors,
or even character pairings that last less
than a minute and needed much more time before
cutting away.
House of the Dragon never feels like they
are missing out on development and every character
interaction and moment is fully realized.
We aren’t getting thrown out of scenes jarringly
like Jon Snow being on the verge of telling
his sisters his identity, and instead, we
have a complete beginning, middle, and end
for each scene.
None of that bullshit lazy writing from season
8 is here and it’s refreshing that the writers
are competent at writing long and fully fleshed-out
dialogue scenes.
Which on the subject of dialogue, it’s pretty
good here.
Now it isn’t as outstanding as it is in
Game of Thrones given that it’s pulled directly
from George RR.
Martin, but I think the writers still did
a great job in house of the dragon.
I’m honestly surprised and did not have
high hopes for the dialogue going into the
show since the source material doesn’t really
have any to draw from.
And they still managed to make some quotable
lines that still stick with me after finishing
the season.
I will not sit here and suffer crows that
have come to feast on their corpses.
Not to be suffocated by all this f***ing politicking.
What is this brief mortal life, if not the
pursuit of legacy?
History doesn’t remember blood, it remembers
names.
She can have her answer now stuffed in her
father’s mouth along with his withered cock.
Let’s end this mummers farce.
So even though the dialogue isn’t technically
as good as Game of Thrones, that doesn’t
mean it’s not great.
Because Game of Thrones-level dialogue is
a very hard bar to clear on its own.
Overall for the story, it was still able to
be really entertaining without relying on
any major twists to throw the narrative into
the stratosphere.
Especially since each episode had some form
of major confrontation going on that always
kept the audience engaged with what was happening
with every character.
Because of this, no episode felt underwhelming
and the show felt really consistent in terms
of the strength of the plot.
Looking at the characters, I think we have
an amazing roster here.
To me, the standout is definitely Viserys
Targaryen.
The way his character balances wanting to
keep things peaceful while not wanting to
overly address conflict is an endearingly
wholesome quality despite it not being a very
good trait for a king.
Since he’s such a pure-hearted character
it’s a tragedy that he meets such an agonizing
and slow death.
This transformation is so jaw-dropping and
the ability to visually track his decay throughout
the season was a great idea from the writers.
Paddy Considine seamlessly blends between
these points of taking on increasingly more
pain and taking on the burden of trying to
hide it and appear stronger.
I love the small details starting out where
you can subtly see he’s hurting on the inside
but he doesn’t want to show it.
That meticulously planned-out acting of focusing
on the intricacies is brilliant and seeing
it progress towards the later and more grievous
stages of his death was outstanding.
What I think is single-handedly the best moment
in the show is Viserys smiling at the last
supper and witnessing his family be happy
for the last time.
It makes me cry thinking that he died a happy
man and this was the last drop of pure joy
he could witness in his sea of misery.
Every scene with Viserys was great and I’m
rooting for Paddy Considine to get an Emmy
win.
The next standout character is definitely
Daemon.
It’s kind of hard to describe the man.
He’s cunning, smart, suave, sexy, unpredictable,
brave, and loves to get his hands dirty.
He’s kind of the likeable wildcard of the
group and because of that, it makes him so
intriguing.
Not to mention that Matt Smith is pretty goated
and it feels like he slips right into the
character.
Otto Hightower is just an absolute babe and
you can’t dispute that.
Rhys Ifan and his hypnotizing gravely voice
made every line he spoke so varied and detailed.
I played a montage of him saying your grace
in a prior review so I feel like I should
play that again here.
Well must I say it your grace?
Your graceheh.
Your grace.
Your Grace.
I’m sorry your grace.
That’s hardly how I viewed it your grace
eh.
Well you honor me your grace.
Yourghh graceee.
The character in essence embodies what I love
so much about this universe which is the political
manipulation that he channels really well.
Episode 9 where he’s ruling with an iron
fist and making people change allegiances
was extremely chilling and I can’t wait
to see more of that in the next season.
For Rhaenyra, I’d say I liked the younger
actress a bit more, and not saying that Emma
D’arcy was bad by any means and she did
a great job in showing a more mature version
of Rhaenyra, but the emotional depths that
Milly goes to for young Rhaenyra was astounding.
Any scene in which she’s exploring the hardships
of growing up and dealing with that immense
conflict of responsibility was engrossing.
I love how she’ll go through a journey in
each episode and then arrives at a major confrontation
that severely changes her as a character.
And that’s normally shared between her and
Viserys and their scenes together were so
precious.
Such a good actor and I’m excited to see
her career take off from here.
For Allicent, I liked both actresses pretty
equally.
I think Emily Carey was a bit more reserved
in terms of breaking and getting upset and
holding everything in, which she did perfectly,
meanwhile, Olivia on the other hand, was really
good at unleashing those emotions and exploding.
The scene within episode 7 where she rushes
Rhaenyra with a blade was an amazing showcase
for her and she’s just so goddamn expressive
with her eyes.
Then I really like how they made Allicent
have a strong moral conscience in comparison
to Otto.
It kind of gives you someone to root for on
the green side of the coin and allows you
to sympathize with them.
Some people may prefer the more bold and evil
villains like Joffrey and Ramsay, but having
a villain who isn’t entirely bad and is
more self-serving is refreshing.
That’s why I think Tywin is the best villain
in Game of Thrones because he's a good guy
at the center of his story, but he does terrible
things.
And the same can be said for the hightowers.
Technically what they are doing is wrong since
they are defying Viserys’ wishes, but it’s
realistic to try to seize the power for themselves.
Along with the fact that having a male ruler
is probably more supported by the common people.
So I really enjoy this civil war style conflict
in which you have characters on either side
that you can agree with.
Although the blacks are much more portrayed
as the good guys here.
We’ll see if that remains to be the case
since Rhaenyra will probably do some heinous
things next season from how mad she was in
the ending scene.
One major aspect of House of the Dragon that
is a significant step up above Game of Thrones,
is the increased production value.
The cinematography, music, set pieces, locations,
and VFX were all expertly done and since they
had such a high budget to pump up these production
pillars, the show was able to flourish.
The cinematography in particular was very
different in comparison to Game of Thrones,
and so much to the point that it was kind
of jarring at first.
Because the first few seasons of GoT feel
more grounded and naturalistic in their approach,
while here, the lighting in particular feels
more cinematic.
So many scenes had stark contrasts that made
them feel moodier and more dramatic.
Along with their overall color grade playing
into that feeling.
Also, I think there were more impressive shots
like anything within the stepstones was delicious,
how they accentuated key character moments,
more usage of shallow focus to bring out depth,
and more dynamic shots like rack focusing
between two different characters.
Every scene is uplifted by this great cinematography
and makes it feel like you are actually watching
something that’s expensive.
For locations, initially, I thought they were
going to overly rely on the volume to film
scenes, but they actually went to some beautiful
places.
For example, locations for Dragonstone were
basically filmed on a mountain.
It was so hard to film there that they had
to helicopter in equipment and set up tonnes
of infrastructure.
The result from all this work pays off because
it fleshes out the world when you can realistically
film in it, instead of faking it in the volume.
Not to say that the volume is bad, but overly
relying on it hurts the scale of your show.
However, when they do use it, like the confrontation
scenes outside of Dragonstone, it’s seamless
because it fits into the already large collection
of real locations.
That’s a great way to make these fictional
places feel real.
Since the creators had a bigger budget, it
just feels so liberating for them to fully
spend it and not hold back on where they wanted
to film.
Like these large beaches during low tide in
which the crew only had a small window of
time to film was probably pretty expensive
to shoot at.
But it pays off because the footage they manage
to capture was gorgeous.
Then for the sets, they did not hold back
at all and they basically made the entirety
of the fictional locations they sought to
create.
The red keep is just one big set with a bunch
of connecting rooms and Dragonstone is grander
on top of having a much better atmosphere.
The steam permeating from the ground and even
the war table glowing up were such nice touches
that weren’t in Game of Thrones.
It’s also more logical to spare no expense
on these sets because of how many scenes take
place here.
It allows the filmmakers to have a lot more
versatility within these scenes when they
are able to shoot in any direction.
Like my favorite showcase was during the oner
of Rhaenyra walking with her baby to Queen
Allicent and they essentially walk through
the entire set, showing off its pure scale.
I truly wasn’t disappointed by any setpiece
in the show and even the VFX was outstanding.
It’s nice that HBO has had a lot of practice
doing dragons because they look fantastic
in this show.
Primarily due to the fact that they have different
and distinct designs and don’t look like
carbon copies of one another anymore.
This also allows each dragon to show off a
certain personality like the scary and unsettling
way Caraxes noodles around his neck.
Or granny Vaghar slowly moving around given
how massive she is.
Which they also did a great job in communicating
the scale of the dragons.
Like Aemond having to climb up Vaghar like
she was a tower or whenever they position
a dragon near one of our main characters as
a size comparison.
They do not shy away from showing off their
dragons and that’s also a refreshing aspect
because you can fully see them in any night
scene.
Generally, when VFX is done at night it’s
always intentionally done to hide the VFX,
but during Vaghar’s two flight scenes, you
can clearly see what’s going on.
And since they don’t hide anything it makes
for some insanely good scenes.
Vaghar’s last scene in the finale because
of this, was easily one of the best from how
terrifying and scary it was.
Truly a very immersive experience.
Then that’s just the visual side of things
because Ramin Djwadi is back for the score.
The man is still killing it and the new themes
he created for the Velaryons and Rhaenyra
were so good.
The chorus chants of Rahenyra’s theme immediately
gives you this uplifted feeling that is so
addictive to listen to.
I also love how it all culminates in her ending
scene when she becomes queen in the track
called “The Crown of Jaehaerys”, I’d
definitely recommend checking it out along
with “The Power of Prophecy”.
Then the Velaryon theme sounds so unique with
its tribal-like woodwinds playing with drums
and violins accompanying it.
It’s so fresh and distinct that it makes
me crave to see Ramin Djawadi flex and experiment
more within Westeros.
And since we are on the subject of themes,
it’s kind of disappointing that there wasn’t
a new main theme for House of the Dragon,
and they instead used the one from Game of
Thrones.
It would make the most sense to me to combine
the themes of Rhaenyra and house Targaryen
for the title sequence but oh well.
I think this sets more of a lazy precedence
for other spin-off shows that are in development
and hope they don’t follow down the same
path.
Because it would be weird to hear the same
game of thrones theme in every single show.
Especially since the upcoming Sea Snake show
as an example, already has such a cool theme.
But yeah, since the budget for House of the
dragon is so big, the production value of
this season is able to ascend and the result
is truly amazing.
So after going through all of these scintillating
positives, let's talk about some of the negatives
that bring the show down a little bit; starting
with the pace at which the story moves.
Not in the sense of how quickly each scene
plays out because if anything the writers
take their time on a scene-to-scene basis,
but more of the fact of how fast time moves
between episodes.
AKA time jumps.
Now it’s really hard to avoid this fact
given that the writers have to cover about
20 to 30 years of time within 10 episodes.
Personally, I think it would have made more
sense to do a longer season so they didn’t
have to skip so much time and avoid that jarring
feeling of having to restart the show again.
I think Lancel needs to get the showrunners
the season stretcher.
Because the main issue with doing these time
jumps is firstly, you are skipping over a
lot of plotlines.
My biggest gripe is getting thrown into these
developments at the mid/endpoint and we didn’t
get any buildup for them.
The worst examples of this is Ser Harwin Strong’s
relationship with Rhaenyra and Daemon’s
relationship with Laena Velaryon.
Within episode 6, both Ser Harwin and Laena
die and you don’t feel that sad for them
because there was no time to build an emotional
attachment to these characters.
The whole point of build-up is to make us
care about them and understand who they are.
So when you don’t include it and throw their
death at us suddenly, then we are going to
feel detached and the death has a soft impact.
That and it’s also just confusing to see
a character go from killing their wife to
then being in a family with a bunch of kids
in the next episode.
So having to essentially re-meet these characters
and have to be introduced to what is happening
again shouldn’t be the aim of the writers,
and instead, naturally get to that point by
taking more time to tell your story.
Then there’s also the aspect of how old
the actors look.
Now to me, I don’t really care about this
aspect that much, but it does become visually
confusing when someone like Criston Cole doesn’t
age at all within the 20+ years the show takes
place in comparison to other characters who
age a lot.
Like hell, the character Aemond gets born
in-between episodes 5 and 6, and he looks
just as old and if not older than Criston
Cole by episode 8.
So to that degree, it feels a bit inconsistent
in terms of how they age up the characters,
but you kind of have to just accept that aspect
of the show.
Because the only option they have is to constantly
keep changing to older actors or use makeup,
which using makeup I don’t think would really
work.
So to change actors every 10 years within
the show would be even more jarring than just
having the same one to me.
The fans were already losing their minds when
they swapped out Milly and Emily for their
older counterparts.
So doing that more frequently I think would
be much more annoying.
So I think this just comes down to people
having to accept that part of the show since
there isn’t a better alternative to take.
For the last flaw of the season, there are
a couple of big changes the writers make within
the story that I think needed to be re-written
or needed some time to breathe.
The first example of this is Criston Cole
snapping and killing Joffrey.
The reason why this development doesn’t
work well is that they immediately do a massive
time jump after it happens.
So any big questions relating to this event
are instantly disregarded and aren’t addressed
again.
Like will there be any repercussions for Criston
Cole doing this, does Allicent defend him
from being kicked out of the Kingsguard, does
Criston lie about the event, and even if he
does wouldn’t that further taint his honor
that he cares about, and do any of the witnesses
care to make a statement?
It doesn’t make sense to hit the skip button
right when we get to the peak of Criston’s
arc.
There are so many aspects surrounding this
major story development that need to be resolved
and the fact that the writers do a time jump
over all of it is insane to me.
This kind of ties back to the repercussions
of doing time jumps but I also think this
was a sloppily written scene.
Because there are some contrivances within
this scene like the crowd randomly turning
into a moshpit for no reason, other than to
forcibly instill a moment of confusion and
chaos.
Going into another big change they made that
I feel like needed to be reworked, we have
Rhaenys bursting through the floor of Aegon’s
coronation and letting the greens live.
In the book, she wasn’t even in Kingslanding
when this all went down and the writers made
this change to quote on quote give Rhaenys
a bigger moment to shine.
Which firstly, that doesn’t really track
well because Rhaenys here is killing hundreds
of bystanders.
So this immediately deteriorates my view of
her since she probably could have taken another
exit within the caves.
Then secondly, you are basically asking the
audience to get annoyed when a character has
the option to eliminate the entire threat
of the show but chooses not to.
Now I do agree with the character decision
here for Rhaenys, however, I feel like the
writers should have made her choice ambiguous,
by establishing an external conflcit that
forces Rhaneys out of the scene.
Like another dragon showing up from the pit
or archers being posted up about to shoot
her.
With these misfires of endings, it hurts an
already good episode and makes them end with
a whimper.
In the grand scheme of things, this isn’t
a major seasonal issue, but it does impact
two episodes.
So yeah, going into House of the Dragon I
was not expecting the show to be this good.
Given that Ryan Condal didn’t have an impressive
slate of past work and the source material
offered little to no dialogue to work off
of.
So the fact that they were able to make a
season this great really blows me away.
I’m immensely looking forward to season
2 and since the story will most likely be
more consistently riveting than this season
on a story basis, I’m very excited.
Thank you for watching and if you are at all
curious as to what I think about other popular
movies, then I’ve probably rated them on
letterboxd.
I generally don’t have enough time to make
videos on everything I watch so if you’re
curious you can follow me on there and see
what I’m watching currently.
I haven’t really put any attention on this,
so yeah, the link will be in the description
and thank you in advance if you follow me
on there.